so generally with benzodiazepines at  least out here you're told that you need  to do a very very slow taper  but his academia was so severe  that he couldn't tolerate a taper so  every time he went down it got worse  but it was just completely unbearable  where he was at as well  and we brought him to russia because  they  they they offered a detox which is  something  that you're not supposed to do with  benzodiazepines but he was  really close to dead and we did a detox  there  and he was eventually stabilized with  suboxone and low-dose mirtazapine  and that worked so he he's  he's almost off everything he's doing  really well he's probably doing better  than he has in  in years anyway um since the ssri  withdrawal on the benzodiazepines but it  was  suboxone and mertazapine and a  benzodiazepine  detox that ended up helping him